- Welcome back everybody.
Our next guests are all about
pure and true rock and
roll. They're so good.
They've proven it for
decades with albums like
Brothers, Lonely Boy, El
Camino, and Delta Kream.
Their latest album out 20
years after their very first LP
is called Dropout Boogie.
Now performing on my
show, "It Ain't Over."
Give it up in the Black Keys.
(crowd cheering and applauding)
(lively rock music)
♪ Money and love ain't no sure thing ♪
♪ You live for a thrill,
you die for a dream ♪
♪ And when it comes around ♪
♪ You lay your money down ♪
(lively rock music continues)
♪ You got a love that's a real longshot ♪
♪ Breakin' the bank for
your new weed spot ♪
♪ And she comes around ♪
♪ You lay your money down ♪
♪ No one else but you to blame ♪
♪ But when you play that losing game ♪
♪ It ain't over ♪
♪ So try to ease your worried mind ♪
♪ Dreams come true from time to time ♪
♪ It ain't over ♪
(lively rock music continues)
♪ What are the odds if you let them roll ♪
♪ Win or lose, it's gonna take your soul ♪
♪ And you can't turn around ♪
♪ Lay your money down ♪
♪ One up your sleeve might
get you two in your chest ♪
♪ Hurt in your heart, but baby know best ♪
♪ And when she comes around ♪
♪ You lay your money down ♪
♪ No one else for you to blame ♪
♪ But when you play that losing game ♪
♪ It ain't over ♪
♪ So try to ease your worried mind ♪
♪ Dreams come true from time to time ♪
♪ It ain't over ♪
(lively rock music continues)
(guitar playing)
♪ No one else for you to blame ♪
♪ But when you play that losing game ♪
♪ It ain't over ♪
♪ So try to ease your worried mind ♪
♪ Dreams come true from time to time ♪
♪ It ain't over ♪
♪ No one else for you to blame ♪
♪ But when you play that losing game ♪
♪ It ain't over ♪
(slow guitar playing)
(crowd cheering and applauding)
- One more time let's hear it
(crowd applauding)
for The Black Keys!
(crowd cheering)
Pick up their album Dropout Boogie
wherever you purchase your music.